Ja.
Guten Tag. Mein Name ist Sarkaan Cialian. Ich bin die Asserbender der Stationauti.
Ich würde gerne eine Anamnese gespricht mit Ihnen dürfen und Sie sein verstanden.
Ja klar, Hauptsache mir hilft jemand ja.
Wie ist Ihr Name?
Ich heiße Frank Beathke.
Frank, könnt ihr Sie bitte Ihren Nachnamen bustabieren?
Ja, B-E-T-H-G-E.
Beathke.
Beathke?
Und ich bin ein Mann, Frank ist ein Herr.
Herr Beathke, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 45.
45.
Ja, 45.
Wie sind Sie?
Und?
Bitte?
Wissen Sie, wie groß Sie sind?
Ich bin laut Pass 178.
178? Wie viel wiegen Sie?
Ja, wenn meine Wahr gerecht hat, 114 Kilo.
114.
14.
Herr Beathke, was führt Sie heute so?
Ah, wissen Sie, ich habe seit heute Nachmittag mit einmal ganz plötzlich
solche extremen Schmerzen in meinem Fuß,
und zwar im linken Fuß,
so vorne da, wo die große Zähel ist.
Das ist mit einmal auch ganz heiß und rot und tut so weh.
Das ist wie angeflogen, ja?
Und es sind ganz, ganz starke Schmerzigkeit, überhaupt nicht auftreten mit dem Fuß.
Und ich habe mich aber nicht verletzt.
Also bei der Arbeit ist mir nichts draufgefallen.
Ich trage bei der Arbeit auch Sicherheitsschuhe.
Also da ist mir nichts passiert.
Mir ist nichts drüber gefahren, nichts draufgefallen.
Aber oh, das sind solche heftigen Schmerzen, das klopft und es heiß und und brennt
und es sehr, sehr schmerzhaft.
Herr Beathke, könnten Sie bitte zeigen,
wo die Schmerzen genau sind?
Ja, also am linken Fuß, wenn wir den jetzt so nehmen,
dann wäre es praktisch hier so in diesem Bereich.
Ja, meinen Sie erste große Hörer?
Im großen Zäh, ja, im großen Zäh unten.
Genau, da tut es sehr, sehr doll wird.
Aber das strahlt in den ganzen Fuß auf.
Das fühlt sich an, als ob das gebrochen wäre.
Seit heute Vormittag haben Sie gesagt?
Nein, seit heute Nachmittag.
Ich bin direkt hierher gekommen, weil das so plötzlich gekommen ist.
Ich hatte mich heute Mittag nach der Arbeit ein bisschen hingelegt
und dann bin ich aufgewacht, weil es mit einmal so doll wie getan hat.
Wir hatten noch gut zu Mittag gegessen
und danach fing das dann mit einmal an.
Herr Beathke, unsere Anamese gespricht dauernd
um ungefähr 15 bis 20 Minuten.
Könnten Sie die Sendung an Amese gespricht halten
oder soll ich Ihnen einen Schmerzmittel verabrechen?
Nein, wenn ich das still halte, geht das sehr schlimm.
Ist es nur, wenn ich versuche, da drauf zu stehen.
Aber wenn ich das hier still halten kann, dann geht das ja.
Alles klar.
Dann könnten wir weiterreden.
Ja, ja, ja.
Sie haben erwähnt, dass er Klopfende brennende
und schütterlern in den Ganzentursch.
Vermuten Sie etwas als Auslöser, Herr Beathke?
Ich kann mir das gar nicht vorstellen,
was solche Schmerzen im Zähn macht.
Wie gesagt, ich habe mich nicht verletzt.
Ich verstehe Sie.
Könnten Sie, wie stark sind diese Schmerzen auf einer Schmasse,
wobei nun kein Schmerz, sondern am stärksten Schmerz ist?
10.
Also, das sind schon sehr, sehr krasse Schmerzen.
Ich würde sagen, zwischen 7 und 8 sind die.
Sie sind schon 7 und 8.
Hab ich etwas dagegen eingenommen?
Nein, ich bin jetzt, weil ich mich so erschrocken habe,
ich bin direkt hierher gekommen.
Alles klar.
Wie helfen Sie auf jeden Fall, Herr Beathke?
Bis auf diese Schmerzen.
Falls Ihnen noch etwas Ungeweniges?
Ja, das ist mit allem auch ganz dick und rot.
Ich habe das ja angeguckt, Sie haben gedacht, was ist denn da los?
Und das fühlt sich auch heiß an.
Also, Herr Beathke,
jetzt wollte ich Ihnen einige Fragen zu Ihrer allgemeinen
Gesundheit hier anzustellen.
Wie sieht Ihre Schlafqualität aus?
Können Sie gut ein- oder durchschlafen?
Also, ich schnarche nachts und deswegen wache ich oft auf
oder meine Frau rempelt mich an.
Und sagt, ich soll aufhören zu schnarchen.
Aber manchmal merke ich das auch selber
und dann kann ich selber nicht einschlafen.
Also, einschlafen und durchschlafen geht beides nicht so gut.
Ist das seit Langem bekannt?
Das ist schon länger, ja.
Langem.
Ist der Appetit gut, Herr Beathke?
Ja, Sie sehen es ja, ne?
Also, meine 114 Kilo habe ich nicht von ungefähr.
Ja, ich bin ein leidenschaftlicher Esser.
Nehmen Sie Genugflüssigkeit zu sehen.
Ich meine ungefähr 2 Liter täglich.
Das kriege ich ja schon alleine mit einem Bier fast hin.
Und wenn ich dann noch ein bisschen Kaffee und Zildrinker
und bei der Arbeit, wenn es warm ist, trinke ich natürlich auch noch was.
Also, 2 Liter trinke ich bestimmt am Tag, ja.
Alles klar.
Fühlen Sie sich fiebrig, Herr Beathke?
Nee, fiebrig fühle ich mich eigentlich nicht.
Aber ich habe das Gefühl, dieser Fuß kocht, ne?
Sie fühlen im Fußbereich.
Da fühlt sich das heiß an.
Ja, ich verstehe.
Wie ist das mit dem Wassellassen?
Haben Sie beschwerten mit dem Wassellassen?
Nee, normal.
Nee, habe ich eigentlich nicht.
Und mit dem Schutulgang?
Ja, normal.
Das ist alles normal, würde ich sagen.
Ich kenne das nicht anders.
Herr Beathke, haben Sie in deiner Lesterzeit ungewollt?
Ab oder zu genommen?
Nein, leider nicht abgenommen, aber auch zum Glück nicht zugenommen.
Es ist alles stabil eigentlich.
Ich habe das Gewicht schon lange so.
Haben Sie in der Nacht,
haben Sie bemerkt, Ihnen und Ihnen danach zu warm ist?
Dass mir zu warm ist.
Ihnen danach, mussten Sie...
Ja, jetzt, wenn es sehr heiß war, dann habe ich geschwitzt in der Nacht.
Aber normalerweise,
wir haben nicht so ein warmes Schlafzimmer,
ich kann eigentlich, an der Wärme liegt es nicht.
Herr Beathke, ich möchte noch einige Fragen
so in der Fußschmerzen stellen.
Haben Sie Schwelchung bemerkt?
Das habe ich doch gesagt.
Das fühlt sich so dick und heiß an und sieht auch komisch aus.
Dick?
Und Bewegungseinstinkung?
Ja, ich kann das überhaupt nicht bewegen,
ich kann da ja nicht mal drauf treten.
Ich würde jetzt auch nicht versuchen,
mit den Zehen zu backen, das tut alles weh.
Früher hatten Sie ein Hemdbeschwer, oder?
Nein, so etwas habe ich noch nie gehabt,
deswegen bin ich ja so erschrocken,
deswegen bin ich ja gleich gekommen.
Und nur diese Fußbereiche,
nur große Sehe, nicht andere Gelenke.
Anders tut es immer umdrehen, nicht weh.
Aber da tut es umso mehr weh.
Alles klar, danke schön, Herr Beathke.
Jetzt hätte ich einige Fragen so wie das Vorgeschicht.
Lassen Sie mir an irgendwelche chronische Erkrankungen?
Chronische Erkrankungen?
Ja, ich bin ein bisschen zett,
das wissen Sie.
Und mein Arzt hat mir auch mal gesagt,
dass die Leute ein bisschen zu hoch sind,
aber bisher habe ich da nichts gegengenommen.
Das war mir eigentlich so ein bisschen lästig, diese Geschichte.
Seit wann leiden Sie ja ein Blutfettwerk?
Ich leide ja nicht darunter, ich merke das ja selber gar nicht.
Wenn der Arzt mir das nicht gesagt hätte,
wüsste ich das gar nicht.
Aber das ist schon ein paar Jahre her.
Da hat er mal so ein Check gemacht
und da hat er mir gesagt, ihre Blutfettwerte sind zu hoch.
Da hat man natürlich auch gesagt, ich soll abnehmen,
aber das ist natürlich schwierig, wenn es einem gut schmeckt.
Sie haben recht, Herr Beathke.
Ansonsten haben Sie andere Krankheiten?
Nee.
Also als Kind so der Klassiker,
dass ich da mal ein blinderem Operation hatte,
aber sonst nie, ich bin immer gesund gewesen.
Wie alt waren Sie, wenn Sie operieren?
Bei der Blinder-Operation?
So zwölf.
Alles klar.
Herr Beathke, sind bei Ihnen allergie in besungsweise
um Tatsächlichkeit bekannt?
Nein, ich wüsste nicht, dass ich auf irgendwas allergisch bin
und essen kann ich nun wirklich alles, ja.
Nehmen Sie ganz kurz die Bekannte.
Nehmen Sie ganz kurz die Medikamente,
die wir gern mit besungsweise, bedarfweise ein.
Zum Beispiel gegen Blutfettwerte.
Was mir der Arzt mal gegeben hat,
ich hatte mal so eine Zeit lang ziemlich so soot brennen.
Und da hat der Arzt mir Omeprazole gegeben
und das nehme ich aber eigentlich nur ein,
wenn ich gerade heftige Beschwerden habe,
normalerweise, vergab ich nicht.
Nur Omeprazole, keine mehr.
Sonst nichts?
Und ja, was weiß ich, wenn ich Schmerzen habe,
weil ich irgendwie zu schwer gearbeitet habe
oder wenn ich einen dicken Kopf habe,
dann nehme ich wohl auch mal Aspirin ein, ja.
Herr Beathke, ist Ihr Impass komplett?
Mama, bitte, ich habe die Frage nicht verstanden, akustisch.
Ist Ihr Impass komplett?
Mein Impfpass?
Ja, Impfpass.
Oh ja, wenn ich ihn dann finde, ist er komplett.
Also ich weiß sicher, dass ich gegen Corona geimpft bin.
Und sonst ja, im Zuge der Impfungen für die Kinder
und so haben wir das immer mal aufgefrischt,
wenn uns da was aufgefallen ist, dass der Bedarf war, ja.
Und dadurch, dass ich bei der Arbeit
also viel ja auch so mit Metall
und ja, was, was ich so mit schmutzigen Sachen auch zu tun habe,
habe ich auch immer mal wieder eine Tätternussimpfung bekommen.
Haben Sie ihn zufällig dabei, Herr Beathke?
Nee, der liegt natürlich zu Hause, den habe ich in der Eile vergessen, ja.
Alles klar, kein Problem.
Sind Sie in den letzten sechs Monaten irgendwo hingereist?
Ja, wir waren mal an der Nordsee, aber sonst waren wir nicht weg.
Herr Beathke, wir sind fast fertig mit unserer Manamesegeschichte.
Nur ein paar Fragen noch.
Sind Sie raucht?
Nein, ich habe noch nie geraucht.
Nehmen Sie Alkohol zu Sie?
Ja, also Alkohol.
Regelmäßig trinke ich ein paar Flaschen Bier am Tag, ja.
Täglich ein Flasche Bier?
Nein, täglich zwei, drei Flaschen.
Zwei, drei.
Ansonsten nehmen Sie doch alle ein Bier.
Nee, sonst, also mal schnappst, wenn es etwas zu feiern hebt,
oder noch ein Sekt oben drauf oder so.
Aber also, regelmäßig trinke ich das Bier.
Herr Beathke, nächste Frage ist eine Routine.
Nehmen Sie bitte nicht persönlich.
Haben Sie Erfahrungen mit anderen Drogen?
Mit Drogen?
Ja.
Nee, also für so einen Quatsch habe ich wirklich keine Zeit.
Nein.
Alles klar.
Nun hätte ich einige Fragen zu Ihrer familiären Manamese.
Sind Ihre Eltern gesund?
Nee, das kann man wirklich nicht sagen.
Also meine Mutter ist zum Glück gesund, aber mein Vater,
der ist schon verstorben, der hatte Darmkrebs.
Wegen Darmkrebs.
Wie hat bei Ihrem Vater, wenn er starrt?
Oh, der war 82.
Ihre Mutter hat keine chronische Erkrankung.
Wüsste nicht, dass die irgendwas hat?
Ich glaube, die ist ziemlich gesund.
Ja.
Haben Sie Geschwister?
Nee, Geschwister habe ich nicht.
Herr Beathke, Sie haben erwähnt, dass Sie mit Ihrer Frau
nicht richtig verstanden.
Ja, ich bin verheiratet.
Und haben Sie Kinder?
Ja, wir haben drei Kinder.
Sind Sie gesund?
Ja, das letzte hat es da und sind brum.
Das ist natürlich unser Sorgenkind.
Herr Beathke, Sie sind berustetik.
Ja, ich arbeite als Maschinenschlosser.
Und da in der Werkstatt geht es ziemlich rupig zu.
Deswegen habe ich auch erst gedacht, ich hätte mich da verletzt.
Aber wie gesagt, da ist nichts passiert.
Sie haben keine Verletzungen, keine Umfragen.
Maschine, als Maschinen-Schlosser.
Ich repariere Maschinen und baue sie zusammen.
Alles klar.
Herr Beathke, meinerseits habe ich alle wichtigsten Fragen gestattet.
Was soll ich wissen?
Ich wüsste jetzt natürlich gerne, woher es kommt, dass es solche Schmerzen sind.
Und was kann man dagegen machen?
Herr Beathke, ich habe schon meine Vermittungen.
Aber es ist noch zu viel, etwas Bestimmtes zu sagen.
Zuerst möchte ich die Köpferlihung untersuchen.
Dann Blut abnehmen.
Dann mit den Befunden prähen wir zusammen.
Ja, okay.
Und wird das lange dauern?
Ich würde ein paar Stunden im Kauf nehmen.
Also muss ich ein paar Stunden rechnen.
Dann rufe ich gleich noch bei meiner Familie an.
Das bin ich auch nicht warten.
Alles klar.
Vielen Dank.
Bitte schön.
Hallo Herr Beathke.
Ernere Sie sich ausgewogen oder wie oft essen Sie Fleisch oder Fleischprodukte?
Fleisch esse ich am liebsten zu jeder Mahlzeit.
Ich könnte schon zum Frühstückwurst essen.
Okay, danke schön.
Könnten Sie bitte Ihre Sehnschmerzen, Gena-Beschreibe,
die Zehnschmerzen?
Ja, sie haben schon gesagt und gerötet.
Ja, sie sind klopfende und stechende Schmerzen.
Klopfende und stechende.
Was sieht Ihre Schweldung aus?
Gerötet.
Es ist gerötet, ja.
Gerötet und ja so angeschwollt.
Es gibt jetzt ein paar Tausende, die haben nicht erwähnt.
Mit einem Mal hat es angefangen.
Ich kann nicht erkennen, dass es eine Auswirkung gibt.
Das ist ja auch das erste Mal.
Deswegen bin ich ja auch sofort hergekommen,
weil ich das nicht einordnen konnte.
Kontrollieren Sie Ihre Fußgegenpilze zum Beispiel?
Fußpilze.
Ja, gut.
Dadurch, dass ich regelmäßig Arbeitsschuhe,
also so Sicherheitsschuhe trage,
da muss man schon zwischendurch mal gucken,
aber Fußpilze habe ich nicht.
Rechte Seite, Bein, irgendwelche Geschwollung ist.
Ist das rechte Bein auch geschwollt?
Nein, das ist jetzt im Augenblick noch unauffällig gewesen.
Ich hoffe, das fängt nicht auch noch an.
Haben Sie allergien oder Unverträchtigkeit?
Hat er verneint.
Er hat gefragt und der Doktor hat gefragt und ich habe das verneint.
Okay.
Guten Abend Herr Betl.
Hallo, seid ihr von? Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ach schon lange, seit ich 16 bin.
Okay.
Und haben Sie Erkältung oder Mandelnentzündung in den letzten Monaten?
Eine Erkältung?
Ja, mal so ein bisschen husten, schluckfen hatte ich schon,
aber eine Mandelentzündung hatte ich nicht mehr.
Okay.
Und leiden Sie unter Herzstraßen oder Herzstolpern?
Nein, mit dem Herzen habe ich nicht.
Ich habe nur diese Fußschmerzen, diese schrecklichen.
Fühlen Sie Sie allgemein abgeschlagen?
Ja, jetzt im Augenblick bin ich schon beeinträchtigt durch diese starken Schmerzen.
Aber eigentlich, vorher habe ich mich nicht schlecht gefühlt.
Okay.
Gibt es an der Betreöffelung Stelle Mückenstich oder eine kleine Wunde?
Also ist mir jetzt nicht aufgefallen.
Ich wüsste aber nicht, wo mich Insekten gestochen haben sollten.
Also ich habe, aber danach habe ich wirklich nicht geguckt, muss ich ehrlich sagen.
Okay, vielen Dank.
Sie haben gesagt, Sie können nicht auf dem linken Bein auftreten.
Genau, auf dem linken Fuß.
Ich habe mir bemerkt, dass Ihre Beine muskalschwer her oder taubhaus gefühlt.
Mit Taubheitsgefühl habe ich nicht.
Und an den Muskeln liegt das nicht.
Es ist nur so schmerzhaft, dass ich da nicht draufstehen kann.
Ich denke alle Fragen gestellt.
Können wir als als gespielte Anfang?
Es ist er wieder.
Guten Tag Frau Oberarztin.
Heute habe ich einen neuen Patientin aufgenommen. Darf ich Sie vorstellen?
Ja, natürlich.
Der 45-jährige Patient, Herr Franz Betges, stellt sich heute, wegen seit heute Nachmittag,
er hat aufgetreten, ausgeprägt, versichert, einige Klopfen,
in großen Städten, links, begleitet mit Rötung, Schwellung,
überwahrung sowie Schmerzbedingte, Bewegung,
bei uns auf der Station vor.
Die aktuelle Schmerzintensität liegt laut dem Patientin bei 7 bis 8,
auf einer Schmerzskala.
Weitere und vegetative Beschwerden vom Patientin gehören.
Ein so wie die Schlafstörungen, der seit langen Bekannte Schlafstörungen,
so wie die Nachgeweiß.
Und dann vor der Krankung leidet der Patienten die Hyperkolesterin
im Zeitentag.
Darüber hinaus musste der Patient eine Operation wegen Appendectomy mit 7 Jahren untersehen.
Da musste sich eine Operation unterziehen.
Die Fragen allergieren sowie Unverträglichkeiten wurden von den Patienten verneint.
Die Medikamente, der Patient, die Präsortabletin, die wir als eine Tabletin beibet haben.
Der Info ist komplett, die Reisen am Nese ist in den letzten 6 Monaten unabhängig.
Der Patient ist kein Rauch, Alkoholkonsum beträgt bei 2-3 Flaschen Bier täglich.
Seit 2010 lebt ein Sier, seit 2010.
Das war der nächste Roman, der Anamnese.
Andernfamilie, Anamnese, Ligen, Kolonkarsinum.
Andernfamilie, Anamnese, Ligt, totali, herzsals Kolonkarsinum mit Zweiun,
als Todessurzahe für die Zweite Reisenfamilie, Anamnese, Unabhängig.
Der Patient lebt mit seiner Frau, hat 3 Kinder.
Der erste Kind leidet am Down-Centrum.
Die jüngste, Entschuldigung, die jüngste Verbrecherung.
Bei der Vorstellung präsentierte sich der Patient im normalen Allgemeinszustand,
sowie Adiposen-Ernährungszustand, also Körper per Grat, 178 cm, Körper per Gewicht ist 104 kg.
Erbettke ist als Maschine-Schloss in einem Werkstatt berüstet.
Was ist denn jetzt Ihre Verlacht-Diagnose?
Die Erkobene, Anamnestische Nanga und Beutelnaume,
Entschuldigung, Bittanfall, differenzial Diagnostisch,
kommunin Atritis, sowie Rheuma im Betracht.
Und das könnte es möglicherweise noch sein?
Keine Verletzung, deswegen, ich sage nicht.
Haben Sie danach gefragt nach der Verletzung?
Entschuldigung?
Hatten Sie nach einer Verletzung den Patienten gefragt?
Ja.
Und war nix?
Nein, keine Verletzung genommen, umfalt.
Aber was könnte es unter Umständen noch sein?
Ein bisschen exotisch vielleicht?
Ulcus curret, natürlich, in Yurika.
Ja, eine Durchblutungsstörung, ne?
Dass er eine Durchblutungsstörung im Fuß hat, könnte auch sehr schmerzhaft sein.
Aber Artikulär-Irika möglich?
Das heißt...
Hat er ja schon gesagt?
Hat er schon gesagt, Giftanfall?
Ja, okay.
Pils, Pils, Fußpils, Infektion.
Pils, Infektion, ja, die müsste schon sehr hoch explodiert sein, ja.
Wie für den?
Lümpfer dem?
Ja, ein Grundgelenk, ja, nicht so wahnsinnig.
Aber die ist ja nicht.
Ja, also könnte man, eine PAVK oder so etwas müsste man ausschließen, würde ich sagen.
Natürlich, großzähn, ein südlicher und schmerzhafte Bedürftel, Halux rigidus.
Halux rigidus.
Ja, beziehungsweise, wie sagen wir, wie sagen wir für diesen Symptomkomplex,
wenn das Großzähn Grundgelenk so extrem schmerzhaft ist?
Podagra.
Podogra.
Podogra, Fußgist.
Bitte?
Podogra.
Podagra, also in Deutschland sagen wir Podagra, das ist typisch für die...
Ja, genau.
Ja, also Entzündung des Fußzähngrundgelenkst als Symptom der Gicht.
Okay, gut.
Was machen Sie mit dem Patienten diagnostisch?
Ja, so erst würde ich dort alle untersehnen.
Worauf achten Sie da besonders?
Inspektion auf Überwarnung, Schwellung, Rötung des Betroffenenbereichs.
Alpassion des Betroffenengelenkst Bewegungseinschränkungen.
Und was machen Sie mit dem anderen Fuß?
Bleibt ja angezogen?
Fuß?
Rechte Fuß, was machen Sie mit dem?
Vergleichen.
Ja, genau.
Mit dem rechten Fuß, vergleichen.
Genau.
Schwellung.
Dann kann man das besser einsetzen, ne?
Ja.
Gut, und was gucken Sie noch?
Ja, in Rahmen der Routineuntersuchung für die Herz- und Lungenoskulation.
Okay, ja.
Und was machen Sie weiter?
Blut nehmen.
Ja, Blut abnehmen.
Blut abnehmen, ja.
Im Blutbild kontrolliere ich Entzündungsparameter.
Neeren Leberwärter, Handsohle, Sonderes.
Ja, genau. Das wäre jetzt im Augenblick der Fokus, ne?
Dass man guckt, ist die Handsohle erhöht.
Und außerdem...
Was erwarten Sie?
Für Handsohle, meinen Sie, oder?
Handsohle, erhöhte Handsohle.
Ja, wir erwarten Sie.
Ja, 6 mg desilitrophilates.
Ja, genau. Sehr gut.
Erinnerung.
Und üren Status, Siebex-5-2-Handsohle im Üren.
Dann...
Apparatum-Tarzu-Hung-Mürdei...
Röntgen durchführen.
Ja, weshalb würden Sie eine Röntgenuntersuchung machen?
Damit wir auch Silicium andere Verletzungen Knochen brachen.
Genau, eine Faktur aus.
Das wäre vielleicht noch so eine denkbare Differenzialdiagose,
die wir damit reinnehmen sollten,
dass wir überlegen, das könnte auch eine spontanen Faktur sein, ne?
Mhm.
Denn ich meine, der bringt ja doch ordentlich Gewicht auf sein Fußgewölbe damit, ne?
Ja.
Gut, also Sie röntgen.
Und, ja, wenn sich der erhöhte Serumhandspiegel da,
der Hansöre-Spiegel bestätigt, was machen Sie dann?
Als Therapie, meinst du, oder?
Ja, also dann hätten wir die Bestätigung, ne?
Dann hätten wir die Bestätigung.
Und das würde man dann machen.
Aber erste Diagnose.
Mhm.
Die Stamphal-Erste Diagnose.
Ist die erste Diagnose?
Ja, ja.
Ist die Diagnose.
Ja, der Patient hat ausgepräktisch messen,
deswegen wäre es aufreichend analgesi.
Genau.
Aufreichend analgesi.
Und die Pyrithnisolone kann sein, ja, kann helfen,
steroid, steroid, meine ich.
Asteroid?
Asteroid.
Als Hans-Soyne senkende Therapie,
Allopyrinol, wo der Siphasson.
Stimmt.
Allopyrinol.
Alle Purinol, sagt mir, was Sie verstehen.
Das ist für Langfristig, ne?
Residiv Profilaxe.
Residiv Profilaxe ist Allopyrinol erforderlich.
Genau.
Ja, Koalchizin, genau.
Das habe ich ja auf dem Zettel stehen.
Dass man Koalchizin im Akut-Anfall gibt, ne?
Nein, nein, Herr Profilaxe,
der Akut-Anfalle müssen wir erst mal gut gekocht kochen.
Dann kochen.
Ah, okay, gut.
Ja, bei Makut-Anfall geben wir steroids,
so wie Analgetikum zusammen, dann machen wir Kochizin-Therapie.
Kochizin-Therapie.
Ja, ich habe vergessen zu erwähnen, ja.
Gut.
Ja, was würde man den Patienten langfristig empfehlen?
Diese beschwerden sich häufig,
verbummt mit Alkohol, so wie vielleicht proteinarm Essen.
Deswegen würde ich Ernährungssperraturung empfehlen.
Proteinreich im Essen.
Proteinreich.
Ja.
Reifenessen.
Ja, ja, ja.
Ja, ja.
Und Niko hat keine Entschuldigung,
unser patient hat keine.
Aber er ist übergewählt.
Also.
Des Polyl급.
Auch Ernährungssperratur empfertig.
Genau, das sind sicherlich die Punkte.
Und ich bin mir jetzt nicht sicher,
dass wissen Sie wahrscheinlich alle besser.
Wie schnell geht so ein Gichtanfall vorbei?
Bei einem Akutanfall?
Langzeittherapie.
Nein, ich meine, also jetzt der Akutanfall, der hat jetzt ja wirklich sehr starke Schmerzen.
Ja, sehr starke.
Und die Frage ist, wie lange hält das an, wenn man den jetzt mit Schmerzmittel behandelt und mit dem Theroid?
Wie schnell wird das besser für den?
Ja, ich meine, die IV-therapie, das ist nicht sehr lange dauert.
Dauert nicht lange?
Und dann reguliert er sich auch von alleine wieder runter und dann gehen auch diese Entzündungsthenomene wieder weg?
Gibt es eine Massnahme, Frau Gerhard?
Ja.
Ich habe die Massnahme erst mal hoch dosiert, die ich jetzt mit dem Theroid verbrechen habe und dann langsam, langsam, in der Nacht, dann ja mindestens 20 Tage.
20 Tage?
Aber die Schmerzen hat ja noch schneller weg?
Ja, schneller weg, aber wir müssen ja kurz nachher die Dosmasnahmen...
Und die muss man dann ausschleichen, ne?
Ja.
Ja, ja, aber die, also ich meine, diese Schmerzen kriegt man noch relativ zügig in den Griff, oder?
Die Adakioate-Schmerztherapie mit der Pyrätinzölone, das ist, sind reicht.
Und dann, dann koşest du, aber nicht mehr diese Medikamente verbrechen.
Die Ursache sind...
Die Ursache sind bekämpft, ja, klar.
Meine Frage war...
Die sind allopyrinal, müssen wir allopyrinal lange Zeit verbrechen.
Als Dauermedikament.
Ja, meine Frage war jetzt nochmal, wie lange hält dieser akute Gicht-Anfall an?
Gibt es da jemanden, der Erfahrung hat?
Ich weiß es nämlich nicht.
Ich habe nur einen Patient gesehen im Hausarztpraxis und die akute heftige Schmerz hat ungefähr ein paar Tage gedauert.
Ach doch, wenige Tage, okay.
Genau.
Ja, dankeschön.
Das war die Info, genau, die ich haben wollte.
Dankeschön.
Ja, okay.
Also, nach einigen Tagen geht es dem wieder besser und dann kann der auch wieder mit seinem Fuß laufen und auftreten.
Gut, ja, wir sind jetzt ein bisschen von unserem Schema abgekommen.
Ich bin natürlich jetzt wieder die Obererstin und sage dann also, ja, also Herr Kollege, dann schauen Sie doch mal, was mit dem Patienten ist.
Ich bin gespannt.
Wenn an den Röntgenbildern irgendwelche Auffälligkeiten sind, dann zeigen Sie mir die Bitte und ich bin natürlich auch sehr gespannt auf die Laborwerte.
Und dann können wir nachher nochmal zusammen nach dem Patienten gucken.
Ja, okay.
Entschuldigung, ich konnte nicht ganz gut feiern.
Was soll ich machen jetzt?
Okay, also die Oberärztin hat jetzt, wir haben jetzt ja über andere Sachen geredet und ich bin ein bisschen aus der Rolle rausgeschlüpft.
Jetzt sagt die Oberärztin nochmal, ja, also gucken Sie nochmal nach dem Patienten und berichten Sie mir über Ihre Untersuchungsergebnisse.
Ja, also ich möchte das Röntgenbild gerne sehen und ich möchte auch die Laborwerte gerne sehen.
Ja, wenn Sie den Patienten untersucht haben.
Und dann gucken wir weiter.
Ja, gut.
Ja, Sie sind, glaube ich, sehr souverän mit der Sprache.
Da habe ich eigentlich wenig Grund zum Kritisieren gefunden.
Sie sprechen manchmal ein bisschen, ja, wie soll ich sagen, manchmal konnte ich sie nicht so ganz gut verstehen.
Aber ich würde schon sagen, dass die ganzen Formulierungen ziemlich astrein waren.
Nur eine Sache habe ich mir aufgeschrieben.
Wir helfen Sie. Nein, wir helfen Ihnen.
Ja, ja, Ihnen.
Ihr habt es sofort gemerkt, wenn ich sage.
Ja, gut, also wir helfen Ihnen.
Ja, und, ja, und was mir aufgefallen ist, Ihr Anfangsatz, der war sehr solide formuliert.
Er war zwar auch wieder sehr vollgestockt mit Informationen.
Sie haben sehr viele Infos da reingepackt, aber es ist Ihnen gelungen, den roten Faden von Ihrem Satz zu behalten.
Also, er stellte sich mit dem Krallala-Hubsa, was es alles war, vor.
Ja, also das war, fand ich, ziemlich gelungen, wobei ich immer denke, im normalen Fall würde man so nicht sprechen,
sondern das ist so ein typischer Text, den man so schreiben würde.
Ja, wenn man spricht, macht man eigentlich nicht solche komplizierten langen Sätze,
sondern dann unterbricht man eigentlich häufiger, damit die anderen auch noch mitkommen.
Aber für eine geschriebene Formulierung wäre es natürlich perfekt gewesen.
Und wie gesagt, es war auch sehr exakt formuliert, das ist mir aufgefallen.
Wenn irgendwas zwischendurch war, habe ich immer gleich gemäckert, zum Beispiel mit der Tochter
oder mit dem jüngsten Kind, was das Down-Syndrom hat und nicht das Älteste.
Und alles andere war, glaube ich, ja, die Schmerzgala war drin.
Und als ich überlege, irgendwas war mir eben noch beim Besprechen aufgefallen.
Augenblick mal eben, guck mal.
Ach so, ja, das fand ich gut, dass Sie nochmal erwähnt haben.
Sie haben ja am Anfang Größe und Gewicht nicht gesagt, aber dass Sie nachher noch mal drauf hingewiesen haben,
dass der Patient eben deutlich übergewichtig ist.
Weil das natürlich im Zusammenhang jetzt mit der Diagnose klar eine wichtige Information war.
Ja, gut, insofern würde ich sagen, das war für den Staat doch super.
Ja, heute ist, das muss ich überlegen, Dienstag.
Wir sehen uns Sonnagsdach schon wieder, übermorgen.